سمح بالنشر على هذه العباره يستفيق
الاسرائيليون منذ احداث السابع من اكتوبر
وهي مقدمه لنشر اسماء الجنود القتلى في
معارك غزه كل يوم وتشير المعطيات الى
ازدياد مستمر في عدد القتلى والجرحى
ينشرها الجيش تدريجيا ليخفف من
وطها على الشارع
الاسرائيلي وهذه الاعداد تقول ان الجيش
يتكبد خسائر فاتحه بدات مع بدايه عمليه
طوفان الاقصى بتسجيل اكبر عدد من القتلى
خلال يوم واحد في تاريخ حروب اسرائيل
بعدها ارتفعت خسائر الجيش مع بدء توغله
البري في داخل غزه وتضاعف معدل عدد قتلاه
اليومي بعد انتهاء الهدنه في الاول من
ديسمبر وذلك وفقا لمعطيات نشرها المعهد
اليهودي الدراسات
الامنيه يضاف الى ذلك خسائر ماليه هائله
ناجمه عن ابقاء اكثر من
350 الف جندي من قوات الاحتياط في الخدمه
لكن هذه الخسائر لم تغير بشكل جذري من
موقف الشارع الاسرائيلي الداعم للحرب وقله
فقط تطالب بوقف اطلاق النار من بينهم
عائلات الاسرى محتجزين في
غزه من الصعب على الاسرائيليين تقبل هذه
الاعداد من القتلى لكن من جهه اخرى الشعور
السائد لديهم انهم يحاربون دفاعا عن
بيوتهم وان هذه الحرب عادله وهم يريدون ان
ينتهي الامر دون ان يذهب ثمن الضحايا
السدا لا يسمح الجيش الاسرائيلي بنشر عدد
الجنود الاسرى المحتجزين في غزه باعتبارها
معلومه تخدم موقف فصائل المقاومه كذلك فان
الاعداد التي ينشرها عن عدد الجرحى اقل
مما يتحدث عنه قسم اعاده تاهيل الجنود في
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وقد اعلن انه
تعامل حتى الاسبوع الاول من ديسمبر مع
2000 جندي اصيبوا بجراح صنفوا على اثرها
كمعاق في الجيش وحتى هذه الاعداد تظل اقل
مما تنشره قوائم المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
التي تقدم العلاج للجنود المصابين والتكتم
على هذه المعلومات من جهه الجيش هو جزء من
المعركه نحن الخمي نحن لا نحارب في ارض
المعركه في غزه فحسب بل ايضا لاستعاده
هيبه الجيش ومن اجل رفع معنويات المواطنين
كي نواصل الحرب علينا ان نقول اننا
منتصرون لكن لو اضفنا الى عدد القتلى الاف
فال المصابين والمعوقين ومن اصيب بالضراب
نفسيه ولا يقتصر الامر على الجنود فحسب
وهذه النقطه ايضا لا يذكرونها عندها يجب
وقف الحرب فهذا ضرر كبير ومقارنه بحروب
اخرى فقد سجل الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه
الحرب اكبر عدد للقتلى بعد حرب اكتوبر عام
3 ومع ذلك توصف بانها الحرب الاقصى
والاكثر ايلاما بالنسبه لاسرائيل منذ
اقامتها اذ ثمت خسائر اخرى لا تحسب
بالارقام والاعداد فالحرب بدات بفشل
استخباراتي وامني غير مسبوق اعاد النظر
بقوه الردع الاسرائيليه وانه بعد 75 عاما
ما زالت اسرائيل تخوض حروبا على
وجودها نجوان سمري الجزيره من منطقه غلاف
غز za